he is a broadcasting legend for NBC
spirit to me the legend himself Bob
Costas is over here alright okay brain
damage in the NFL yeah well I mean it's
so funny because whenever you're here I
always say you know Bob's here and we're
gonna talk about sports issues cuz there
are these big sports issues but he is so
much more than just sports and then I
look at the issues and I'm going
yeah but sports somehow gets to all the
big issue that really are bubbling up in
our society it often intersects despite
the mouth-breathers who say leave it all
out of sports I just tuned into here
there's a ground ball to shortstop fine
okay Wow don't call the mouth-breathers
Bob they're your bread-and-butter that
mistake before but I mean look we could
start anywhere the big news that was all
in the papers yesterday was Aaron
Hernandez right where it was a great
tight end for the New England Patriots
except for the fact that he murdered
people and then he held himself and went
to jail for it and that damn end well
but they what they found out yesterday
was that the CTE which is let's not even
try to say what it is but it's the brain
damage you get from chronic Lyme addict
encephalopathy he knows things like that
I mean it means your brain scramble it's
scrambled and this this kid had problems
anyway but they said for twenty
seven-year-old they never saw it that it
was stage three and four is the worst 27
at 27 and we know that even before
dementia sets in that brain trauma even
for active players can have an effect on
impulse control or anger that sort of
thing but it can't make the leap to
connect what he did directly to that
because he's just one person but this is
more bad news in an accumulation of bad
news for the NFL and
football in general and this comes from
somebody who recognizes the drama the
excitement the teamwork the strategy
that's all very interesting and
appealing and it remains the most not
just the most popular sport it's the
most popular thing in all of American
entertainment and it's difficult for
people to give up that attachment and
the generational connections but
evidence is evidence you can't turn your
back on it I you know what and as a
libertarian I I've spoken out and said
and I'm kind of torn about it and said
look these are young people when I was a
young person try to take the joint out
of my hand back when it was illegal kids
and now NFL players want to use
marijuana to salve the pain and it works
yeah so we have a solution but but you
know it's hard to tell somebody because
when you watch the NFL on TV when
they're not writhing on the ground in
pain they're having a great time they're
celebrating they're fun they're young
they're out doing their thing in it to
tell somebody you can't do that we're
gonna take away your living but even
though he it's different if they didn't
know it was harmful for them we're kind
of indirect territory which was the case
in the 60s and 70s when players may have
thought look right I might have trouble
getting out of bed because my knees or
my hips will be bothering me when I'm 50
but they didn't think they wouldn't know
what day it was
right now you do have informed consent
you pretty much any football player who
doesn't know what he's getting into
hasn't been oh but but there's also
evidence that the earlier you start
playing you start playing peewee
football and participation is way down
because parents are concerned about it
if you start playing when you're 12 13
14 years old then the long-range effects
are apt to be even greater
so the idea probably will evolve that
they should play flag football learn the
game's fundamentals and then when you
get to an age of consent get to be 18 or
something then if you want to play
tackle football play tackle 14 the
Commissioner is starting to sound like
the mayor and jaws you know
it's there's no shark and if we close
the beaches now we're gonna lose a lot
of money but but but it's gonna have to
change at some point because I'm telling
you even as a libertarian I was watching
the game the other night and you know a
guy who's just crunched and he's you can
see him in pain and the guys in the
booth are like alright let's go to
commercial as quickly as we can there
we're gonna clean up the body parts
after this word from Del Monte and and
you know they just kind of gloss over it
but even I the libertarian I'm going oh
god I I'm feeling a little like I need a
shower after watching the game what
would you answer me this let me out to
the bottom line where is it gonna be in
ten years what is the NFL gonna look
like in ten years
well I believe it's gonna be the same
they've they've changed the rules which
is only fiddling at the edges because
the game is fundamentally brutal and
violent but they have changed some of
the rules they're trying to change the
culture they're trying to change youth
football they say they're funding
research but unless they come up with
some as yet unimaginable mcc's to the
point where it doesn't just protect
against the skull fracture but it
protects the brain from rattling around
inside the skull like a pickle inside a
jar which is really what happens is
somehow they can come up some technology
that disperses the impact unless that
happens basically you're just gonna have
to sign a willing assumption of risk
Clause to your contract and it may
become like the Roman you know circus it
is where people watch it but they don't
let their kids play it well it already
is a little like that it's also much in
the documentary in Vietnam the Ken Burns
thing now it's a little like that where
oh thank you the Vietnam vets are
yeah it's terrific but it's a little
like that craft involved in both cases
and who goes you know the the people who
were more desperate yeah well you know
where the risk is justified by the
reward yeah but I mean who went to
Vietnam you know the poor kids
minorities and you know that's what foot
on the other hand Tom Brady wants to
keep playing if he can't at least 45 or
50 you know you watch Aaron Rodgers play
there's something exhilarating about
that
you can't deny not just the rare skill
but there are times when the athleticism
is almost poetic you recognize all those
things I wish there was a button I could
push that would make the game rough yes
tough yes but not life-threatening and
brain threatening and then you could
still enjoy it but those two things
cannot separate let me quickly ask
because I can hear Martin's getting very
antsy but not when the camera is not on
him for five minutes I feel he started
kicking me under the table I'm here too
but Colin Kapernick I mean again an
issue race that in sport right you know
maybe this is the place where we should
play this out now I think a guy should
be able to not stand for the national
anthem
even people who disagree with them
that you'd be crazy to deny the right of
expression that the people they rightly
revere for having put their lives on the
line to protect it and insure it that
why would you deprive someone of that
right even if you disagree with right no
I understand Trump said something today
at his rally he said something to the
effect of I'd like to see some NFL
owners say when someone does that kneels
or whatever just get the son of a [ __ ]
off the field but in effect you do have
a lot of players who are presently under
contract and players that their teams
think are good enough to really help
them that are engaging in that kind of
protest but in effect the owners
collectively have told Colin Kaepernick
to get the hell off the field because he
doesn't have a team now there's he is he
Tom Brady or Cam Newton no he's not but
is he better than some starters in the
league and better than any backed ups in
the league of course he is it's
definitely because of that I wonder why
more aren't doing what he did I'm always
surprised when I see on this I thought
it's only a few I think the possible
reason is that they recognize that
there's some complexity in this that the
anthem doesn't just represent the
nation's flaws or it doesn't just
represent the military or the police as
admirable as most policemen are even
given the road cops and as admirable as
the sacrifice of military is but that it
represents the nation's ideals as well
that's what makes this a little bit
complicated if I owned the team which I
don't but if I owned a team I would have
the PA guy say please stand for our
national anthem and in recognition of
the ideals it represents that would then
encompass conservative liberal and
everyone in between and I think would
make it more palatable